allez de retour dans les Yvelines
direction Villepreux la Ville lance sa
Semaine du développement durable pour en
parler avec nous Laurence Morel Losson
vous êtes adjointe au développement
durable pour la ville cette année vous
avez choisi le thème de l'eau vous nous
en parler en début d'émission l'eau
c'est la vie c'est le thème pourquoi
alors en fait ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'à Villepreux nous sommes on va dire
connu et reconnu depuis un certain
nombre d'années pour nos engagements en
matière de développement durable donc
nous organisons une semaine du
développement durable déjà depuis
plusieurs années en essayant à chaque
fois de balayer les fameux 17 objectifs
de développement durable vous savez tel
qu'ils ont été mises en place par les
Nations Unies mais cette année c'est
vrai qu'on a choisi ce thème de l'eau et
du changement climatique parce qu'on
souhaitait vraiment mettre le focus sur
ce thème voilà qui est on ne peut plus
crucial et pour nous cette semaine du
développement durable est vraiment là
pour sensibiliser en fait les familles
les riverains et donc choisir ce thème
c'est vraiment inviter les gens à se
mobiliser et donc on leur propose toute
une série de d'événements en fait il y a
un peu des choses proposées chaque jour
tantôt sous une forme plus
comment dire conférence scientifique des
choses vraiment destinées plus aux
adultes tantôt ce sont des propositions
plus ludiques pour pour les familles les
enfants mais on essaye de balayer voilà
un spectre large de manière à séduire un
peu tout le monde séduire convaincre
mobiliser enfin voilà alors est-ce que
ce thème de l'eau il est aussi en lien
avec ce que le département vit on est en
sécheresse depuis cet hiver ça
inquiétant on est en état d'alerte
d'usage de l'eau est-ce que tout ça est
lié tout ça est lié forcément après le
choix du thème il a été fait il y a il y
a un an il y avait pas encore l'arrêté
préfectoral qui aurait cru que quand on
aurait un avis de sécheresse en plein
hiver je pense que ni à Villepreux ni
ailleurs on aurait imaginé mais bon
voilà c'était déjà dans l'air du temps
malheureusement donc oui c'est mais ça
ne donne que en plus vous savez
peut-être Villepreux est une ville très
agricole donc nos agriculteurs sont très
sensibilisés sur ce sujet là donc ça ne
donne que plus de résonance clairement
alors au niveau du programme samedi
matin il y aura notamment une visite de
la station d'épuration à Villepreux
qu'est-ce que les villes proviens et les
villes proviennent pourront découvrir et
bien tout le cycle en fait c'est vrai
qu'on ne se rend pas bien compte de la
manière dont l'eau est filtré comment
dire je pense qu'il y a aussi de la part
des gestionnaires du site la volonté de
sensibiliser les gens sur un certain
nombre de déchets qui sont comment dire
jetés notamment les fameuses lingettes
beaucoup de familles utilisent les
lingettes vous savez pour désinfecter la
salle de bain et c'est vraiment une
plaie pour pour les filtres des des
stations d'épuration c'est donc en fait
le but c'est vraiment de leur montrer
tout le le cycle de l'eau et cette
station de de Chatenay Villepreux et de
taille réduite donc finalement on a
vraiment une vision assez claire du
process donc ça c'est ça c'est bien
ensuite on a différentes autres
propositions
le dimanche on a une visite sur un axe
plus historique en fait on a souhaité
mettre un focus sur les usages de l'eau
mais au fil des décennies et des siècles
passés donc c'est assez donc on se
baladera à la découverte de citoyens des
lavoirs un moulin à eau qui faisait
fonctionner une manufacture de papier et
qui l'eût cru nous avons eu fin 19ème
une centrale hydroélectrique
au bord du rude Galli voilà c'est ce qui
a permis à Villepreux avant la guerre de
14 d'avoir
chaque foyer connecté à l'électricité
donc voilà c'est c'est des aspects voilà
vous parliez des lingettes tout à
l'heure quels sont les les
usages les bons usages les bonnes
pratiques pour économiser l'eau
aujourd'hui alors ça on a aussi comment
dire des moments qui seront proposés aux
villes pour voilà faire prendre
conscience de ces bonnes pratiques avec
des stands des animations notamment le
samedi
10 ou 11 les bonnes pratiques voilà
c'est le 10 absolument 11 c'est le
dimanche alors on va notamment proposer
un atelier pour fabriquer comment dire
avec des pots en terre cuite des Zoya je
ne sais pas si vous connaissez les
autres ce terme c'est un système qui
était utilisé déjà dans l'Antiquité à
l'époque c'était des sortes d'enfants en
terre cuite non vernisées c'est très
important et elles étaient mis dans le
sous-sol et par capillarité en fait
l'amphore est rempli d'eau et par
capillarité donc elle elle diffuse
autour d'elle de l'eau mais vraiment
avec parcimonie et ça permet aux
plantations autour de l'oya ou d'avoir
de l'eau en permanence sans du coup
pâtir de de la déshydratation du au
rayonnement solaire donc ça c'est une
chose qu'on va proposer nous allons
aussi proposer des permanences dans
notre maison des services publics avec
une les services de France Renov qui
viennent pour voilà conseiller les
riverains qui le souhaitent comment dire
dans leur travaux de rénovation ou voire
même d'installation de récupérateur
d'eau il y a des systèmes de subventions
et tout ça
voilà il y a différents ateliers et
moments où les villes provient pourront
avoir des conseils à ce sujet après il y
a aussi pas le cacher des comment dire
des moments qui seront clairement
ludiques toujours avec une un volet
pédagogique mais ludique on aura un jeu
de existe on aura des animations pour
pour les enfants
voilà bien merci beaucoup Laurence Morel
Losson d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors je le rappelle la semaine du
développement durable à Villepreux ça
débute ce samedi 3 juin et ça se déroule
jusqu'au 10 juin vous retrouverez toutes
les activités et le programme sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
votre écran et surtout si je peux dire
il y a quelques activités qui
nécessitent une inscription au préalable
en ligne notamment avec les associations
qui sont nos partenaires donc c'est
important donc important de le faire
merci beaucoup merci à